hello everyone today I'm going to be
answering some of your questions now
some of these questions are ones that
have been left as YouTube comments and
others are from Instagram so I asked you
for questions on Instagram and I was
really happy that so many of you did
post something and there's some really
thoughtful nice questions there so if
you don't already follow me on Instagram
as well and you want to stay in the loop
next time then I'll have a link in the
description so I've got my laptop here
and I'm just going to go through some of
the questions that I think would be
really interesting to answer so the
first part of this question is if I'm
bad at math should I study physics or
computer science
I find it hard with these sorts of
questions when people ask me like
exactly what they should be studying or
for that sort of life advice because of
course I don't know what you're gonna
actually Excel it I can only speak from
my experience but I think there's
probably a lot more advanced sort of
calculus in a physics course than they
would be in computer science computer
science would be more of a discrete math
both those subjects are going to have
elements of math in them and they're
probably both end up being tricky if you
don't have any math background but I'd
probably say you can get further in
computer science without you know the
knowledge of calculus or differential
equations or some of those sort of quite
tricky math concepts the second part of
this question is is the common
misconception that physics is hard even
true or does it just stem from the
concept that it's easier for some people
to grasp and heart of others there is
definitely sort of the idea that physics
is a difficult subject socially being
when it's being compared to other
subjects and I think it's true to some
extent physics is difficult
but one of the main reasons why it looks
so difficult to people especially that
aren't in physics already is because the
kinds of questions and assignments and
work that you have to do studying
physics you can't just look at it as an
outsider and understand what's being
asked early on in physics you get
swamped with notation conventions and
you really get sucked into this very
niche way of describing the world and
it's something that can be quite
isolating especially things like the
notation and when you get into doing
quantum mechanics with direct notation
it looks like you're writing in an alien
language so it's really not accessible
to someone who's not studying it I think
that's why it seems so hard because you
you can't jump in you have to sort of
start at the most basic building blocks
and go from there
all right another question was can you
give me some tips on how to learn and
understand college-level maths and
physics I'm currently taking real
analysis electromagnetism in quantum
chemistry the problem is that it takes
me a lot of time to do problems and
apply concepts if you can give some
advice on how to increase the learning
rate then that's going to be helpful
yeah it's true that physics and math
problems at a college level are going to
take you a long time to do that's kind
of the point that separates them from
say high school physics is that you use
as you learn these new concepts they can
be so confusing at first that you have
to work through them slowly really
slowly to understand them I spoke about
this in one of my last videos where I
said one of the things I regretted
during my degree was not actually going
slower myself and taking the time to
understand these concepts because to
some extent I don't know if the question
is asking me how to actually understand
them deeper or how to do well in them
because you don't just have to be smart
at the physics here and in college
physics you've got to be smart at other
things like when to stop learning like
when you learnt enough that you need to
move on to the next concept you need to
know what you need to study and what you
need to learn if you try to learn
everything that's presented to you
incredibly deeply I don't think you'd
ever be able to pass because there's
just so much to do you need to be
thinking in terms of I guess how can I
be most effective at doing some of these
example problems but not every single
one so you have to be able to look for
like common trends and what you're being
asked and pick out trends with within
problems and ideas and and just learn
those it's I think almost impossible to
try to do and accomplish every concept
and every problem so to the Instagram
comments there's one what is your
specialization in studying physics so in
my undergrad degree that I did in New
Zealand I double majored in physics and
maths and I didn't specialize beyond
that I know some unis offer you
especially the beginnings with a lot of
courses offer specializations like
Medical Physics theoretical physics
maybe optics something like that and
they offer that at the undergrad level I
just had that sort of board physics
umbrella even though I did a lot of say
astrophysics courses and even some of
the more mathematical physics I don't
really have a label now that I'm doing
my PhD I'm working in an area of
biophysics but it's still just under the
umbrella
PhD in physics direct notation and also
how many females study physics so I have
made a video talking about direct
notation before and I'll try and put a
link to that here but the Sigma part of
the question how many female said in
physics the answer is not many which is
a shame and there's definitely not many
I probably say in my undergrad course I
was at quite a small uni and the whole
class like all the physics majors it was
probably 30 people in total and of those
maybe three or four girls so maybe a 10%
yeah it's really a shame and it does
make it harder I think for women doing
physics to not be surrounded by sort of
like minded others in a sense but
there's a lot of courses are bad I know
math and computer science and sort of
similar numbers I was just grateful I
wasn't the only female which I know some
people have been through that and it
sounds a lot more isolating what books
can I use to study through the summer
right before college physics undergrad
well if you're sort of just coming out
of high school and going into physics
undergrad and you want to get ahead in
some sense over the summer I would
probably just recommend looking up which
textbooks are going to be used in your
undergrad course in that first semester
and reading those because it means that
as soon as you start you will be already
familiar with the content and I think
one of the most vulnerable times for
people in terms of like dropping out of
uni or feeling overwhelmed or behind is
right at the start as you're starting a
new course so if in that first semester
you look at the content you like oh yes
I've done some of this I know some of
this this doesn't seem like such a big
jump from high school then you'll
probably be quite alright at you know
getting back into the rhythm of things
and moving from there if instead you hit
first course really overwhelmed scared
of the concepts because they seem so
alien to you then feeling behind from
the start is really not going to be
helpful so like I know an undergrad
first year I used a physics textbook by
sir--we and do it but I would just pick
whichever one is listed on your unis
website as being the undergrad textbook
what moment or achievement of your
academic career are you most proud of I
mean there's probably a lot of things
I'm feel quite proud of and things that
I did in like my academic career that I
look back on really fondly probably the
proudest moment though would be finished
my honours course here in Australia and
I was able to get first-class honours
which is a certain grade and it's the
grade you need to be able to do a PhD
straight away without having to do a
masters and you can do the PhD with a
scholarship and because of that it's
really like if if you don't get first
class honours which means an average
over 80% then you're adding like a
couple of years on to your study because
you need to go and do that masters or
maybe you might just be worth going out
of academia and doing something else so
I knew that my grade there would be a
turning point for me and I so badly
wanted to get first class but at the
same time I was starting a new uni and I
felt really behind because all the
courses I was doing I feel like my
background at a previous uni wasn't
quite the same so I feel like I had a
lot of catching up to do in those first
few weeks and it was also really intense
coursework and it was really quite
depressing really to to be going through
that and to be so stressed about trying
to get good grades because you only had
one shot I remember thinking like during
some of the
really hard assignments and coursework
that hey if I get first class honors in
this it's going to be the greatest
miracle that ever happened but somehow I
did somehow I think it was more of an
endurance test rather than an
intelligence test the honors system it
was really like can you survive handing
in daily assignments doing all these
exams with not much of a break and can
you just keep going to the end and I
think like I was able to just keep going
and that's all got me through so I think
some aspects of study are really an
endurance test but that was something I
was really proud to get through what's
your learning process and how do you
manage to understand such abstract and
difficult ideas so I guess again that's
the perception that physics is really
hard which I guess it does have a lot of
really abstract ideas and what's your
learning process sort of as I sort of
said before my learning process was
cramming a lot of things into my
short-term memory not a great learning
process I spoke about a better learning
process in another video the Fineman
technique which is um don't just try and
read and absorb the material by yourself
try to work with a group and explain to
them what you're learning I think that's
one of the most valuable things I ever
did was not only asking my friends for
help but living there Master help and
trying to explain things to them it
really really lets you know what you
understand and what you don't
in what ways has physics changed your
perception of the world I quite like
this question I think yeah a physicist
or someone they're really interested in
physics or math and science kind of does
look at the world a little bit
differently I definitely look at natural
phenomena and sort of wonder about the
physics behind
I think there's something to be said for
trying to look at things rationally as
well and and try to understand how
things work because so much of your
physics education will be taking
something that seems like a normal
everyday phenomena or occurrence or a
ball rolling down a slope that most
people will just accept as happening and
you're asked to break that down and
understand why understand what forces
are acting why they're acting where
they're acting and how so many different
elements add together to give the
physical world around us that is why I
picked physics in the first place
because I loved looking at the world
like that
I loved I don't know I guess it's it's
asking why things are the way they are
and I think studying physics just sort
of enhanced that type of thinking I
think most people come in with that
curiosity and going through the process
for three or four years or more means
that you're quite good by the time you
finish at looking at things and having a
bit of an answer for why they work
there's still so many things I don't
understand but the world is a big and
complex place and we can try to explain
what we know but there's a lot we don't
know I do have quite a few more
questions so I'm actually going to split
this up and do a Q&A part two that I'll
upload a little bit later so I don't
answer your question now try answer it
then but also I'll try and answer it
online thanks for watching and thanks
for sending in so many questions I'll
see you next time